your starters for today's game
leading up to zombies
your 2021
san diego
club
what a day it is today opening day 2021
in san diego on the mound for the san
diego padres you darvish
likes to throw that cutter to lefties
that is strike three first k for you
darvish in a padres uniform
this is the good old number one right at
the knees
freeze fastball at 97. oh it's up to as
drubal cabrera one of the new
diamondbacks
two one and two out
breaking ball away cabrera dunks it into
left center here comes cattell martay
and the diamondbacks strike first in san
diego curve ball that stays out over the
plate just off of the outside corner
cabrera goes right with it
that's ball four and they're loaded up
for the ponderos
base is filled with friars uh victor
carratini coming up for his first ap
in a padres uniform
a little blue into center that's gonna
fall from third comes myers cronenworth
behind him throw goes to third the
padres take a 2-1 lead
welcome to san diego victor caratini
drives in two
it's what the padres did so well last
year as this pitch is up he gets jammed
and because it's up he just dumps into
the shallow center field martay tries to
deep the runners with the glove up in
the air they're not buying it
and the guys in pinstripe say sit get
down and the padres take the lead
one down here in the third and that'll
bring up eric hosmer
that's to right field
smith going back at the wall he leaps
and that ball is gone
home run before eric hosner can go into
the truck
his first of 20-21 and the padres take a
3-1 lead
there's something about a home run on
opening day for the hometown nine
oh is he taking a selfie
out there
so cut fastball
well he got extended he went out and got
it and how close was it as you mentioned
he had a chance to get oh it looks like
he made drew a little leather on it very
very little
that's a home run
payoff pitch and myers drives up to deep
left peralta back looking up
padres have gone back to back
hosner now myers it's 4-1 san diego
hosmer getting extended
myers gets the breaky ball this one is
in he's quick to it
and the big kid puts a charge into it
so two down victor caratini who has
driven in a pair today
yeah the padres doing damage on mistakes
out of the hand of bumgarner
lying to left that's in for a big set
chronoworth will be centers the throat
from peralta it'll be cut off and the
padres take a 5-1 lead how about victor
karate he's driven in three today i know
it's opening day but i hope at the end
of the season
third base coach bobby dickerson
needs shoulder surgery reconstruction
because of this wave him home bobby d
and the potteries tack out another one
andre is trying to add on to their lead
with two down here in the fourth inning
hosmer chops one down the line at first
a fair ball into right
around from second comes tatisse hosmer
headed to second has an rbi double and
the padres have a 6-1 lead on opening
day
lift that one hanging a bit this is
driven deep to center field tommy pham
at the wall and that one's gone
could tell martay make it three for
three
and it's six to two first diamondback
homer in 2021 goes to the
mvp candidate ketel martin
as drupal had a good spring hit 326
homeward three times
as drooble hits one deep to right field
goodbye it's gone as drubal cabrera
two home runs in this fifth for the
diamondbacks
and it's a ball game again at petco park
it will be tim lecastro
batting for pavon smith
le castro sends one deep to left field
tim lecastro get out of here
tim la castro the pinch hit two-run
homer and guess what d-backs we are tied
at six
votes so far over two
vogt gets into one is this four
four diamondback home runs in this fifth
inning and they lead at 7-6
eric
two down two on
hosmer grounds one up the middle and by
the diving second baseman marcano's
coming around and the padres have tied
the score seven to seven
eric hosmer driving in a two out rbi
and with two outs
everybody's going over the glove see
that ball went over the glove
and marcano scores
fly ball to left center field peralta
going back over goes martay
he'll make the catch tagging and jogging
home is cronenworth with an 8-7 padres
lead in the seventh inning sac fly for
jerks and profile you see that nice and
easy swing to center field to get the
run home
he realizes the situation don't have to
do too much
thanks to jake cronin with a triple the
padres lead by one
they come to their feet with two down in
the ninth inning
cabrera chops one right side
conelworth the first padres win their
first of 2021 opening day a success for
san diego